I am Conan O'Brien or as I'm known at
Kona common or Comicon fan out in the
streets and the tick in the sheets
why are you so happy about that news I
don't even know what that means yeah
it's not good this is crazy it's my
fourth year here in San Diego fourth
year in San Diego for comic-con I really
think I'm getting to know the city I
really do fun fact I learned this San
Diego is an ancient Spanish phrase
meaning land of chubby Batman's
[Applause]
slurp Batman let me finish this shake
first a lot going on at comic-con this
year Superman turns 80 years old did you
know that yeah you can tell Superman is
80 because now he just sits alone on the
fortress of solitude watching Fox News
yeah it's our country get out
Superman you were an alien shut up
I love kamek kamek the lines are crazy
long here are they not that's insane
one cosplayer ended up waiting so long
for the men's room he had to rename
himself the incontinent Hulk that's a
true story
not yet well you have standards that's
fantastic
I applaud you that was great as excited
as they are and the tickets free and
everyone wanted to come in and they got
in they still were like not that one
the a new trailer for the DC movie
Titans was just released yeah in it a
group of teenage superheroes fight off
their arch-nemesis Kevin Spacey
[Applause]
that started out his outrage and then
turn into joy for some reason course
there's always controversy at Comic Con
the new version of the animated
character Shira was released this week
guess what and a group of male fans are
complaining that she's not sexy enough
yeah they said she doesn't stack up to
the women we already don't date
[Applause]
you